i was sitting behind you at the final
conan show at largo
um which we luckily got to do
a few live shows before the show ended
um and the last one at largo was really
emotional
and it was so sweet at the end conan had
a long list of thank yous to people um
and he gave a really sweet and heartfelt
thank you to you he did so i was
wondering how you felt at seeing that
show if that was emotional for you
um
it's making me emotional now um
i know i uh it's funny because i
was completely unprepared for that you
know he's so
there's like i i call it the separation
of church and state like in our you know
life there's like his his private life
and then his job and and they've just
always been very delineated and and that
makes a lot of sense and uh
and so
it does seem like you know if there ever
were going to be a moment where he would
talk publicly about something personal
you know it's going to be a moment like
that but i still was sort of surprised
by it i did not anticipate it i didn't
know he was going to say anything
about anything in particular um i was
really glad i had happened to take a
shower that day
because they were putting the camera on
us and uh so your hair smelled great
thank you
i don't know i i
um it was an emotional
uh it's so the whole thing so weird to
to wound down at the end of that strange
coveted period was really weird um
so i don't know it all felt very organic
and and authentic to him and and i liked
that and um i loved you know i loved
that i wasn't the only one being singled
out you know i love that sona got in
there and
um and he was trying to embarrass a lot
of people that's exactly right yes i was
in good company um yeah so no he did a
big wind-up but it was like but the one
person i have to thank the most and i
was like okay this better be
i thought it was going to be bill tall
from prague
i mean i literally it could have been
his mother and i wouldn't have been
surprised you know i was not
even at that point in the wind up i was
like okay let's see what this is going
to be about
i don't know
so yeah very very sweet of him though
well they had to ask the network for
more time because i know wow
uh the thank you you know it was
supposed to be a half hour show and i
think it ran
40 minutes 10 minutes gushing about you
that's true love yes how has it been
having him home a little bit more
well i can't answer that one fantastic
it's been great what
um it again i think if we hadn't just
had that weird lockdown period to sort
of break us all in it might have been
stranger but um there hasn't been that
big a change and you know he's still
going off to do podcasting stuff and
he's still
um you know bothering mike sweeney a lot
and matt o'brien a lot um
so
i
for years was terrified of the loss of
that structure you know that it really
was such an organizing principle in our
lives um and we relied on it in a way
even though you know it could be like
too confining sometimes
um
but it hasn't been
um it hasn't been a huge shift and also
uh you know we're at a point in our
family life where it's great that he's
around to like drive someone somewhere
if i need help with that or
you know i've been kind of like
only doing the domestic stuff for so
long that to have him a little bit more
available for some of that is is amazing
not too available we don't want to teach
him how to do things yeah well
yeah i mean i think my nightmare is that
he'll realize that
everything i do is really not that hard
at home he leaves the house and then
hands the keys off to someone who's
hired to drive the kids that's right
yeah
well that we used to compare notes
because
back when i said writer it's when you're
the head writer you're kind of like the
show wife yes
yes so
that's right yeah
it's
and it's kind of a hot potato of oh
thank god he's giving mike a hard time
right now because that means i'm out of
the glare
and now it's matt o'brien so now oh yeah
the new the new sister wife no he's like
a bigamist now i'm like the older guy
instead
he you know you're the one you don't
have to worry about him coming into the
right he's just at night
but
his eyes don't light up the way they
used to
[Laughter]
uh what can you do but the cute thing i
have to say the cutest thing right now
is with sona's babies
we haven't even met them yet but he when
they like in the final week or so of her
pregnancy maybe a few weeks
he was like a grandfather he was like i
can't believe they're going to be born
when i'm out of town i think i need to
be there i was like you do not need to
be there she does not want
yeah she wants nothing to do with you
right now but he's so excited he shows
me pictures of those kids like more
often than i think he may have ever
looked at pictures of our kids when they
were there
they're so cute oh my god it's it's
amazing yeah so he that's a very sweet
kind of um foreshadowing i think of how
he might be as a grandparent as a
granddaddy yeah yeah what a sweetie pie
oh isn't he just a bunny coming around
on him yeah
it's just all sweetness and light